meet Sarah Sarah is a sales professional
and a tungle user what's tungle it's a
calendar accelerator that syncs with
existing EC calendars allowing you to
easily schedule meetings publish your
free busy schedule and share
calendars here's how it works Sarah
wants to meet with John so she opens
tongle and starts a new meeting
invitation she adds a few details
selects John from her contact list and
proposes times her calendar is synced
with tungle so she can see at a glance
which times work best for her she
previews the invitation and
sends John gets the email invitation and
clicks the link to see Sarah's proposed
times he's in a different time zone but
that's okay tungle has automatically
adjusted the times for him he picks one
that works for him and clicks book
meeting he doesn't have to sign up to
reply and could even do it from his
smartphone
once the meeting is booked tongle
automatically updates Sarah's calendar
and sends John an email confirmation to
add to his calendar it's just that
easy Sarah uses tungle for group
meetings too when she wants to meet with
her sales team she simply creates one
meeting invitation and sends it to
everyone it's easy because she and her
team share their calendars through
tungle even though some of them work
from home and use different calendar
applications when proposing times Sarah
simply selects her team from her contact
list and can instantly see their
schedules overlaid on hers making it
easy to propose
times with group meetings each invite
gets a meeting invitation and chooses
all the times that work for them to book
it Sarah can let tungle choose the final
time based on all replies or she can
have tongle notify her when all replies
are submitted and pick the final time
herself
but what if Sarah sends an invitation
and then adds new events to her calendar
that overlap proposed
times tungle will dynamically update all
pending meeting invitations so that
Sarah will not be double
booked and when someone wants to meet
with Sarah they use her tungle meink
tungle lets Sarah publish her free busy
schedule and invite others to meet with
her through her personal tungl me link
which she has added to her email
signature blog LinkedIn profile and even
her business card others can visit her
link to see when she's free and send her
meeting invitations proposing multiple
times without having to sign
up and that's how tungle makes
scheduling quick and easy so are you
ready to
tongle